[Musique]
bonsoir à tous ravis de vous retrouver à
la une de sa bourgade ce soir les
français redécouvrent l'hygiène à la
faveur du coronavirus des gestes simples
comme se laver les mains limite la
propagation de la maladie mais sommes
nous réellement capable de nous y
soumettre l'épidémie nous obligent au
respect à l'altruisme à la solidarité à
la responsabilité mais elle révèle en
même temps de profondes différences
culturelles face à l'épidémie
coronavirus et si on changeait après la
crise fut notre grand débat ce soir
quatre jours quatre jours seulement nous
séparent du premier tour des municipales
cap ce soir sur rouen pour la suite de
notre série à la rencontre des habitants
nous irons aussi en auvergne dans un
petit village vers menton où le maire
sortant raccroche après 25 ans
d'engagement son fils l'a suivi et ça
donne un film la gloire de mon père
dialogue sur ce plateau entre père et
fils dans la deuxième partie de cette
émission et puis notre grand témoin ce
soir aiguise son regard sur la société
depuis des années elle en a fait tomber
plus d'un masque dans ses interviews et
dans ses films elle nous revient avec un
documentaire et un livre qui donne la
parole à ceux qui ne l'ont jamais dit
rail de mât est avec nous ce soir voilà
donc pour le programme c'est parti
hashtags tvr n'oubliez pas on y a
et bienvenue à vous chers
téléspectateurs merci d'avoir choisi lcp
nos invités en plateau ce soir mireille
dumas
bonsoir bonsoir et bienvenue à vous vous
êtes notre grand témoin les français
vous connaissent très bien vous les avez
accompagné pendant des années bas les
masques vie publique vie privée vie
publique à la télévision vous êtes
journaliste vous êtes réalisatrice et
vous êtes productrice on va parler de
votre dernier film et de votre dernier
livre puisque c'est un peu d'eux en est
d'abord un documentaire france de lcp
qui sera diffusé demain soir à 20h30 sur
notre antenne des ordures et des hommes
7 aux éditions rappelez moi ça juste
chez chanel et c'est passionnant parce
que vous donner la parole à une
profession à des hommes et des femmes
aussi on va en parler qu'ils ne l'ont
quasiment jamais et qui dans votre film
on le sent bien avait envie de parler
les éboueurs vous allez nous raconter
pourquoi vous avez choisi de leur donner
la parole mais ce qui est intéressant
dans votre film on y reviendra
c'est ce qu'ils disent aussi de nous et
de nos comportements et je pense que le
thème de notre premier débat va vous
intéresser à plus d'un titre on va
parler de l'hygiène et on va parler du
civisme qui sont au fond les deux
piliers qui pourrait nous permettre
d'endiguer cette crise du cornât virus
bonsoir frédéric saldmann je suis ravi
de vous retrouver sur ce plateau je
rappelle que vous êtes l'auteur à succès
dont on n'est jamais mieux soigner que
par soi même qui est déjà en tête des
ventes c'est chez plon vous êtes médecin
cardiologue spécialiste des modes de
prévention contre les épidémies
vous allez nous dire au fond si on est
champion très mauvais goût des nanas en
matière d'hygiène françois kraus bonsoir
merci d'être là vous diriger le pôle
politique et actualités de l'ifop et
vous êtes l'auteur d'une enquête sur
l'hygiène des français qui a beaucoup
inspiré stéphane stéphane blakowski dans
son billet que l'on accueille tout de
suite si j'ai bien compris c'est parti
torshavn pendant que vous retrouvez
alors oui jamais autant vu si j'ai bien
compris ce soir et ben si j'ai bien
compris
myriam et au docteur salma nous le dira
si c'est vrai mais moi j'ai l'impression
que les français ne sont sont pas
propres des banques en gironde les
salons n'est pas on n'est pas repoussant
au point on est comment dire
mais assez souple avec les règles
d'hygiène élémentaires et en problème en
par deux ans période de coronavirus
c'est là que vient le problème c'est un
problème c'est pas un vieux cliché ça de
dire que les français sont bons ça l'est
cela devrait pas vous êtes un vieux
cliché oui oui c'est un vieux cliché
vous avez avant alors qu'il ya un cliché
notamment d'après guerre il ya un
personnage qui a été créée hollywood de
dessins animés prédire qui s'appelle
pépé le putois pp le pew idée comme ça
donc il a faim c'est la caricature du
français tels que les américains le
rencontrer quand ils sont venus nous
libérer en 45 et donc il est très
français parce qu'il est très arrogant
il est très séducteur et il sent très
mauvais arrogant séducteur je veux bien
mais pourquoi sentirait-il très mauvais
je vais pas l'étude il de ces rues que
frédéric cros nous renseignera mieux
mais bon j'ai bien de repérer des
statistiques de l'ifop qui disait quand
en 51 il y avait pas 10 % des logements
équipés de salles de bains 3% équipées
de douche ou 2b norme qui n'est pas
exclu que les américains quand ils sont
venus nous libérer se sont dit c'est
français dis donc
l'hygiène c'est pas tellement notre
gueule un peu loin du corona virus et
puis les choses ont quand même bien
changé non stéphane depuis les années 50
j'aimerais j'aimerais vous donner encore
raison mais j'ai quand même un doute
parce que certes quand l'on regarde les
stats de l'ifop 90% aujourd'hui des
foyers sont équipés de salles de bains
de la douche mais novice habitude elle
elles seront peut-être pas évolué aussi
vite que le matériel donc je vous
propose de regarder une étude qui date
de 2015 une étude internationale
soixante-trois pays 64 mille personnes
interrogées la question qu'on a posé aux
gens c'est vous l'avez vous
automatiquement les mains avec du savon
après être allé aux toilettes
donc vous avez vu le classement de la
france on est 50e sur 63 loin derrière
les pays musulmans arabie saoudite
bosnie algérie on se lave les mains chez
les musulmans on remarque donc aussi que
la chine est en dernière position de ce
placement marqué à 3 % des chinois qui
se lèvent les mains ça danse quand on
leur pose la question et puis l'italie
mal classés aussi 57e encore derrière la
france donc forcément on repense au
coran navire ils sont se dit finalement
ceux qui déclarent
lavez le moins les mains sont aussi ceux
qui sont le plus touchés voilà c'est
donc la conclusion
alors du coup le truc à ne pas faire
c'est pas courir acheter un masque
immédiatement mireille ça servirait à
rien c'est pas ça qui peut faire c'est
ce que nous dit jérôme salomon donc qui
préside la santé publique en fait on a
toujours tendance à imaginer que le
masque protège or on sait que la
transmission principale elle se fait par
les mains puisqu'on touche en permanence
des surfaces contaminées on touche des
personnes et surtout on n'arrête pas de
se toucher le visage vos noterez
d'ailleurs qu'on se touche le visage
environ une fois par minute
donc si on a des mains contaminé il faut
vraiment penser au lavage des mains et
c'est une très bonne pratique quel que
soit le virus
que ce soit celui de la bronchiolite ou
de la grippe saisonnière parce qu'on est
passé aux bonnes pratiques
est-ce qu'on a changé les français
depuis depuis l'arrivée du jury un autre
problème non seulement on n'est pas très
propre en france mais en plus on ne
manque pas seulement d'hygiène au manque
aussi de civisme en faire moi c'est un
peu mon impression se dire qu'on a
l'impression que quand on fait un truc
si moi ça me dérange pas pourquoi ça
dérangerait les autres prenons la chose
aussi simple que le passage clouté
voilà une règle commune est fait pour
réglementer l'espace public chacun
soumis à la même règle il suffit de le
respecter pour tout se passe bien et on
ne fait bien que d'état d'automobilistes
ne respecte pas des tas de piétons
traversent en dehors des passages alors
avec cet esprit civique qui nous
caractérise ce que vous croyez qu'on va
respecter les consignes du coronavirus
ne serait-ce qu'en pensant aux autres en
essence qu'en dix ans pour ne pas
contaminer les autres
c'est pas sûr mais c'est inquiétant
quand à la fin du suspense je vous
laisse regarder le sondage de l'ifop je
crois je me trompe c'est lui qui disait
que voilà la règle a dit de ne pas
serrer la main même pour les collègues
même pour les proches vous voyez il ya
que 15% des français qui ne sert
absolument pas la main à leurs collègues
de bureau et 9% qui ne font pas la bise
non plus au bureau donc les consignes
sont pas vraiment très fermement
respecter en fait on a des comportements
qui sont ancrées depuis si longtemps
dans nos habitudes dans nos traditions
que l'échangé juste pour la crise
ça serait nécessaire mais ça risque
d'être un peu court c'est désespérant
merci stéphane c'est un peu désespérant
françois cros cette deuxième étude que
vous avez fait pour les phoques entraîne
la première hong kong et sorti en
janvier et qui était pas prévu pour être
livré fin mai
problème du coronavirus 1 et qui
s'appelait pépé le putois mythe ou
réalité
pépé le putois qui est intéressant pépé
le putois qui est en france qu ont été
diffusées étaient traduits en langue
italienne apparaissait comme un italien
alors que dans le monde entier c'était
en français donc il a contribué à ce
cliché du français malodorant véhiculée
par hollywood
à partir des années 50 et qui était
consécutive à la rencontre des gi's
après la deuxième guerre mondiale avec
la population française et ce qui était
intéressant et vous l'avez aussi montré
dans cette enquête internationale c'est
que en fait la question c'est est ce que
les mauvaises habitudes culturelles des
français en la matière en matière
d'hygiène les sur exposé à un virus et
aux risques de transmission du
coronavirus dans la mesure où
aujourd'hui compte tenu des risques
l'application des bonnes règles d'usagé
notamment en matière d'élevage dénonce
pas seulement un devoir à devoir envers
soi-même et pour soi même aussi un
devoir pour pour les autres c'est
aujourd'hui un enjeu de santé publique
qui apprendre extrêmement au sérieux et
pas forcément à la légère comme pendant
longtemps on a traité ces sujets c'est
culturel cette question bien sûr
l'hygiène vraiment notre enquête on a
montré notamment alors ça fait beaucoup
de bruit que il y avait par exemple
aujourd'hui que 1 un homme de 2,2 de
plus de 65 ans sur deux qui changeait de
caleçon ou de slips tous les jours et
qu'on avait une proportion non
négligeable on rompt un gros tiers qui
ne se lavait pas aussi de manière
quotidienne et cela me soulage en fait
parce que les plus âgés parce qu'ils ont
été socialiste et qu'on leur a inculqué
les normes en matière de pratiques
d'hygiène corporelle
à une époque les années 50-60 vous
l'avez rappelé il n'y avait pas le
confort sanitaire de base qui a
aujourd'hui et e
les pratiques qu'ils ont encore
aujourd'hui leur paraissent relativement
normal puisque c'est ce à quoi ils ont
été habités dans leur jeunesse
et c'est pas quelque chose qui change
facilement alors le lavage des mains à
nous on l'a mesuré au mois de janvier
dont 15 avant la crise on la remet
mesuré
il ya une semaine pour voir si les
choses avaient évolué et globalement bas
on voit que malgré le maternant des
messages sanitaires par les autorités
comme l'om est santé publique
france le ministre de la santé on a du
mal à chaque fois par un virus
3 voilà ça dépend un petit peu iliad et
notamment les trois ans après et
transports en commun les choses ont
changé après s'être mouché aussi mais il
faut comprendre que ça c'est des
messages et la bise par exemple on
s'arrêtait plus facilement sur ne
connaissait pas la personne en revanche
si c'est la famille
alors là on a plus de mal je suis c'est
de refaire le respect en matière de ddd
des règles édictées notamment depuis
quelques semaines en matière de contacts
physiques basse heurte à des rites de
salutation de civilité qui sont ancrées
profondément dans les habitudes des
français et ce qui change aujourd'hui
c'est dans le rapport à l'inconnu aux
personnes qu'on ne connaît pas on fait
beaucoup plus attention mais les proches
on estime que c'est des personnes de
confiance et qui vous le désirez nous
sommes à vendre en train de donner 10
était malade il vous surprennent ses
résultats même après le premier décès de
l'épidémie dans le pays
on ne change pas vraiment drastiquement
nos modes de vie oui parce que d'abord
les règles d'hygiène il n'a pas qu'une
c'est pas juste de se laver les mains
nous avons au moins une centaine il faut
les connaître même de se laver les mains
moi je regarde les gens utilisaient le
gel hydro alcoolique il se bénisse les
mains avec mais ce qu'elle nettoie pas
il faut frotter les espaces
interdigitaux les poignets les ongles il
faut penser aux bracelets aux bijoux il
faut penser le soir à brosser ses ongles
avec une brosse à dents mais pas la même
que les dents je veux dire qu'il ya
encore faut-il déjà en avoir parce qu'on
a des enquêtes
aujourd'hui qui nous explique seulement
un français sur trois a acheté du gel
dans le pays
mais je préfère entre parenthèses l'eau
et le savon au gel et l'huile de coude
ça ça marche bien nous le savons c'est
formidable et éduqué avec loïs avons
pour ce le seul truc qu'il faut
connaître c'est éviter la vieille
serviette humide qui parce que les
microbes adore se développer quand on
voit les
mais les méthodes employées par les
soignants jeu via une méthode je lui
avais 11 étapes et il disait il faut le
faire minime entre 40 secondes et 60
cents contre 40 cents des deux minutes
c'est sinon ça sert à rien si on fait il
ya plein de petits jeux en dessous de 40
secondes
on n'est pas efficace ans et regardez
les chances mais tous les doigts dans le
nez vrai cela regardait parmi les
surfaces sur ces surfaces il peut y
avoir du courant un virus
en plus il peut rester quelques heures
mais allemands ont montré qu'il peut
tenir jusqu'à neuf jours dans certains
cas je touche cela si je me mets le
doigt dans le nez ça va du producteur au
consommateur à la c'est directement dans
les voies respiratoires qui pensent à se
laver les mains avant ce geste aussi
banal mais par rapport à la culture des
états des histoires des pays on oppose
souvent le nord et le sud
il ya véritablement une corrélation avec
la question de l'enfant auquel sur le
lavage des mains en fait après les
toilettes que vous avez montré tout à
l'heure c'était dans les pays arabo
musulmans on avait les meilleures
pratiques notamment parce qu'elle y aux
pratiques culinaires on mange plus
souvent avec les mains alors que dans
d'autres pays on mange pas avec les
mains il ya beaucoup moins fait moins
aguerris prodigieux aussi des rétros dit
vous êtes surprise on pas même au plus
haut niveau des représentants politiques
ont eu cette image par exemple en pleine
campagne à quelques jours nicolas
sarkozy qui fait la bise à rachida dati
lors d'un meeting de soutien
on n'y arrive pas alors que c'est
compliqué de semaine un geste barrière
tandis qu'une société méditerranéenne
donc c'est vrai que c'est compliqué de
changer ses habitudes du jour lendemain
là je vois c'est un petit peu n'importe
quoi ce qui se passe parfois on est en
fait le salut de loin et puis quelqu'un
vient vous embrasser et puis vous ne
faites pas ça donc c'est compliqué de
repousser bishop mais non vous n'avez
consignes on les connaît bien sûr qu'on
les connaît est ce qu'on les applique
je pense à un truc parce qu'on a une
vidéo que vous êtes déjà venu nous voir
professeur salman et on avait filmé le
ce qu'on appelle le trafic c'est-à-dire
avant qu'on s'installe et on vous voit
regarder et là vous êtes au fond et fait
carrément la bise à myriam et c'est
qu'on a droit à la vie je peux poser une
question c'est juste là on parle du sol
et moselle mais vous mais finalement
enfin quand il y en a une
me chante grippe ont fait on fait aussi
un petit peu attention enfin je veux
dire c'est élémentaire passer les mains
de jeu décent mouchoirs oui mais je vous
donner un chiffre aujourd'hui le
coronavirus on a moins de 50 décès en
france
oui c'est bien pour ça que je vends la
dernière grippe on a eu à peine 38 17 ce
soir on a eu un 9000 d'essai à la
dernière il ya deux ans on était à dix
huit mille décès et 650 mille cas dans
le monde sont décédés avec la grippe
oui son camp fait revivre c'est ce que
je suis en train de vivre comme le
coronavirus et atteint les sujets les
plus âgés c'est pareil
le taux de mortalité plus importants et
des surgelés virus que la grippe
oui mais quelque part ça atteint les 2
sujets âgés ou des sujets plus jeunes et
qui ont des problèmes de pathologies
associées ça peut quand un virus que ce
soit la grippe
le corps d'un virus claque celle où même
des gastro entérites chez des sujets
fragiles c'est la goutte d'eau qui va
faire qu'un équilibre extrêmement
fragile face rompre donc en définitive
important on est effectivement sur une
épidémie mais quatre pour 95% des gens
ça se passe bien dire il ya plein de
gens qui sont positifs et yoopa de sam
tournoi agrumes voilà quelque part on
est sur quelque chose je veux dire c'est
vrai que on vit en direct chaque jour
les chiffres et tuia on en fait trop en
octobre à moi vous savez ce qui me fait
plaisir c'est que enfin on va apprendre
les règles d'hygiène pas seulement pour
le coronavirus et pour la grille
possible la grippe et la gastro entérite
pour vous savez l'hygiène avait été
abandonnée dans les années 60 parce
qu'on sait dégâts les antibiotiques
c'est plus la peine de s'embêter énormes
erreurs et ses gestes d'hygiène qui est
enseignée à l'école des mamans aux
enfants ont été oubliés bien ces parcs
se laver les mains ya énormément qu'il
foulait les champions de l'hygiène
dans le monde les japonais japonais sont
très forts d'ailleurs inondations se
saluer que j'adore un japonais se
saluent comme ça ce qui fait que si
l'interlocuteur tout si leur tous dans
les cheveux ils ont tout compris des
thaïlandais font comme ça les anglais
pour comme ça et puis les américains ont
un truc formidable c'est le bug c'est en
fait il s'approche mais tourner la tête
et tapote assez ce que vous avez fait
myriam jours vous avez fait un ami
nantes que le serrage de mains on voit
regard des contrôles mais doivent
justement tenté de serrer la main il
fait là haut up un truc c'est difficile
et c'est quelqu'un que ça met en l'air
c'est presque offensant par contre quand
vous rapprochez vous tourner la tête
vous n'êtes pas exposés vous tapotez
c'est affectif et tout va bien
c'est la question rapidement cette
question des l'importance du scolaire en
matière d'implication des bonnes réduit
ce que en france jusque dans les années
50 60
il y avait des programmes scolaires en
matière d'hygiène qui était vraiment
important on le voit encore chez les
personnes âgées si les persos 2 et fo -
leur hygiène intime que les jeunes en
revance ils font plus attention au
lavage des mains aujourd'hui mise de la
santé dans une école avec des petits
enfants et leur faire répéter ce geste
et aux éléments aux états unis il ya des
programmes scolaires en matière
d'hygiène comportait vraiment de manière
des résultats très efficace ya encore
quelques années et qui se traduit
vraiment par des baisses de l'infection
très très net alors cette question de
civisme de la solidarité de l'altruisme
protéger les autres pour se protéger soi
même on le voit qu'elles se posent à à
toute la planète à tous les états et on
voit aussi et dans les réactions sont
différentes on va faire un tour
d'horizon de l'italie à la france en
passant par la chine et le japon s'est
signée hélène bonduelle reste à akaza
rester à la maison
le message est clair pour les 60
millions d'italiens
depuis lundi ils doivent rester confinés
chez eux leurs déplacements ne doivent
être qu'exceptionnel donc nous allons il
n'y aura plus de zone
il n'y aura plus de zone en zone 2 de la
péninsule
mais il y aura seulement l'italie
l'italie toute entière deviendra une
zone protégée zona protect l'italie
cloîtré à l'arrêt pour tenter de freiner
la propagation du virus vers le sud du
pays plus pauvre et moins bien équipés
en termes de santé publique mettant les
déverser l'eau et à l'italie doit être
uni je ne suis pas d'accord avec ceux
qui sont revenus du nord au sud dans
leur famille d'origine
je suis sicilienne mais je reste ici
pour garantir la santé de tous il faut
dire que ces images ont choqué une
partie du pays des centaines d'italiens
de lombardie région confiné dimanche qui
se précipitent dans les gares pour
gagner le sud du pays avant d'en être
interdit je me trompe comme un réfugié
en ce moment
au revoir et c'est dire parce que nous
fîmes érotomane je vous ai dit qu'il y
avait plus de place je sais pas quoi
vous dire moi appelé le ministre dit lui
de faire venir à d'autres trains en
réalité depuis deux jours l'italie aussi
entre civisme et indiscipline oui je
suis sorti par nécessité parce que j'ai
perdu des documents et maintenant je
rentre chez moi parce qu'on m'a dit de
rester chez moi
malheureusement pour éviter la contagion
pourrait travailler de chez moi mais je
préfère aller au théâtre en ce moment il
ya personne fut pratiquement le seul
la france deuxième pays européen le plus
touché par le coronavirus n'a pour le
moment pas décider de mesures aussi
drastiques
mais le président de la république en
appelle au civisme des français pour
tenter de freiner l'épidémie
nous avons chacune et chacun une
responsabilité individuelle
la première c'est de nous protéger de
protéger les autres par des
comportements qui relève du civisme
lorsqu'on a de la fièvre des premiers
symptômes qu'on est malade de ne pas
aller dans les transports en commun de
réduire sa vie sociale et de ne pas
aller au travail le temps d'être sûr de
ce que l'on a ou d'être guéri respecté
les consignes c'est ce que les chinois
font scrupuleusement depuis un mois et
demi dans la province de hubei comme les
foyers du coronavirus 50 millions de
chinois scruté par drones par les
autorités est priée de rentrer chez eux
une méthode draconiennes qui semble
avoir porté ses fruits le président
chinois s'est rendu pour la première
fois hier haouran épicentre du virus
pour annoncer que l'épidémie était
pratiquement juguler frédéric saldmann
comment vous avez compris la décision
italienne du président conté de confiner
l'ensemble de la population le pays tout
entier
ça va pas éviter l'épidémie ça va faire
qu'elle arrive au luc soit des vagues
très hautes de cette salle a ralenti ça
ralentit pourquoi parce que le système
des hôpitaux universitaires italiennes
n'est pas le système français ils sont
moins bien équipés que nous d'ailleurs
les chinois leur envoie des respirateurs
de chine en italie
qu'est ce qui se fait c'est qu'avec ce
confinement il ya moins de gens qui
arrêtent brutalement dans les hôpitaux
qui pourrait pas absorber d'un coup au
lieu que ça arrive
brutal dako
ça va pour éviter des mouvements de
panique et 2 et les migrations internes
pour aller rejoindre les régions où il
ya moins que les hôpitaux puissent
absorber les sujets les plus âgées
vulnérables qui eux font partie des gens
qui ont trop besoin de soins par rapport
à ce virus va mettre l'économie à genoux
et toujours sur la question culturelle
est ce que une décision pareille en
france pour être au fond accepté est ce
qu'il ya une obéissance comme ça dans le
pays qui pourrait se mettre en route
tout dépend de ce qui va être décidé
dans les prochains jours et des
prochaines semaines si tout à coup on
vous demande de rester chez vous je
pense que les français le enfin ce
serait le ferai peut-être un petit peu
plus difficilement mais moi c'est enfin
je trouve qu'on est quand même dans un
qu'est ce que je vais dire dans un
système de précautions qui me semble
quand même absolument drastique et un
spectateur est exagéré parce que alors
je me dis sur les nuits de très mauvaise
grippe je reviens la grille parce que
finalement le coronavirus c'est un peu
on va dire une très mauvaise grippe
un mauvais rhume même si on ne sait pas
bien comment d'où ça vient comment
comment ça va évoluer
enfin bon je ne sais pas mais mais quand
même on n'a pas pris aussi en prenez
autant de précautions pour la grippe on
aurait peut-être aussi limité limiter
les propriétaires m'ont france a dit
c'est pas évident la france et les
français sont pas connues depuis
l'époque gauloise comme un pays civique
dans leurs réfractaires
voilà nos voisins au protestons du nord
après mais on va parler de la propreté
dans un instant avec le fils de mireille
dumas mais c'est vrai que obéir à des
gestes barrières c'est aussi la même
chose que de ne pas jeter des ordures
quand on est un saint thomas dans
certains pays la suisse le japon il n'y
a absolument aucun déchet donc ses hôtes
c'est aussi une question culturelle
bah oui c'est l'éthique du
protestantisme cher à weber le fait qu'
on est beaucoup plus responsable
vis-à-vis de soi-même
en france on a quand même en matière de
propreté de déchets etc
des comportements qui nous situe plutôt
en dessous de la moyenne européenne et
ça se traduit aussi dans l'hygiène
corporelle bref on n'est pas les moins à
risque en tout cas les gars c'est donc
qu'on en vient des fans à votre film
justement à mireille dumas des ordures
et des hommes vous montrer ces hommes et
ces femmes mais vous montrer aussi
l'envers du décor est ce que ces hommes
là les éboueurs disent de nous de nos
comportements de la société de la
surconsommation du gâchis du gaspillage
des déchets balancer n'importe où
regarder un extrait anonyme le sol pour
eux invisibles ils le sont pour nous
aveugle le soap apparemment tous
qui sont ces hommes et ces femmes auquel
nous venons la vie dure et sans lesquels
les villes ne serait qu'un tas
d'immondices il ya là même qui mendient
moi at elle été payés pour ça vous êtes
payés pour ça des fois ça vous
découragez fois vous nettoyez bien
secteur mais ils font n'importe quoi
c'est impressionnant le l'incivilité des
gens je conçois pas jeu alors je dis pas
ça parce que je suis mûr je dis pas ça
parce que c'est moi qui ramasse c'est
juste que je me je conçois pas moi
j'élève mes enfants de façon à ce qu'on
ne jette rien par terre ce que je
comprend pas c'est qu'à paris il ya
énormément d'écolo quand on regarde
c'est quand je veux dire c'est
l'écologie à tout va et pourquoi quand
on regarde par terre c'est sale et c'est
pas la faute du nettoiement parce que
nous on nettoie mais les gens pètent ils
sont écologiques mais dans leur tête
pas dans leurs actes et ça c'est dommage
voilà un petit message qu'il nous envoie
aussi un grand message oui puisque on
jette de façon totalement inconsidérée a
partout n'importe comment on consomme
aussi ce qu'il faut dire c'est qu'on est
dans une société de surconsommation et
dans la société du du déchet et eux
c'est vraiment le rocher de sisyphe 31
sûrement pas compte à quel point ils
passent ils repassent en permanence du
soir au matin et aussi les grands
marchés parce que la vo on parle d'un
petit peu de la collecte sur sur la voie
publique mais ils font bien plus que ça
évidemment oui c'est l'étrange
d'humanité on sent qu'ils avaient envie
de parler couiza données sans être sans
effet avait justement star il avait
envie de passer des messages je n'avais
pas envie de devenir des stars du petit
écran dans l'imaginaire collectif quand
on devient et boire on a raté ça oui oui
c'est pourtant vous à les entendre c'est
pas exactement ça non c'est à dire que
pour pour certains évidemment ils n'ont
pas eu le cursus scolaire qu'il qu'ils
espéraient
comme dit jérôme
celui qui parlait sur le périphérique
des rêves se sont arrêtés aux portes de
la cité à un moment donné il arrêté lui
en cinquième parce qu'ils pensaient
qu'il ne pourrait pas aller plus loin
ce n'est pas tant l'échec d'ailleurs de
l'échec scolaire le leur que l'échec de
l'école je pense que ce sont des ceux
que j'ai rencontrés étaient franchement
une pertinence avait le mot juste son se
dit mince il aurait dû quand même on
aurait dû les pouvoirs les accompagner
encore le plus loin possible mais cela
dit ce ne sont pas justement ils ne sont
pas tous son échec scolaire loin de là
oui on sent qu'il usera choisi ce métier
de ne pas choisir les flamands il ya
donc à lui des petits mais il ya aussi
de la fierté
oui bien sûr de plus en plus de
personnes qui ont leur bac bac + 1 en
italie en particulier d'ailleurs même le
des bac + 4 de plus en plus parce que la
crise est encore plus forte en france
donc ils préfèrent pour certains êtres
éboueurs plutôt que chômeurs alors c'est
un métier extrêmement masculin parce
qu'il est très dur physiquement
singulière des femmes 5 6 % de femmes
sur la totalité des éboueurs et à la
fonctionnelle cette infecte et voilà
j'ai suivi qui est vraiment une unité
spécifique qui a été créée en 82 qui est
chargé des grands événements parisiens
donc ils sont 500 hommes et femmes cinq
femmes c'est à dire que quand j'ai
commencé à tourner les premières
c'était l'année dernière en 2010 9,5
femme sont arrivés tout au long de
l'année
pas évident dans une structure très très
masculine mais elles se sont fait leur
elles se sont fait leur place
est ce que fait cette cette unité ce
comme je vous disais ils sont chargés
donc elle est chargée d de tous les
événements de la capitale à savoir
qu'ils sont très nombreux vous avez 300
manifestations en tout genre les manifs
mais aussi les commémorations fête de la
musique c'est là où vous voyez ces
images absolument terrifiante
franchement de terrifiantes à perte de
vue
des centaines de bouteilles de la
polémique de la campagne à la propreté
de paris
on parle de ran en paris elles sont
confrontées à tous d'ailleurs parce
qu'ils sont ils à des l'incivisme des
gens king john il avait raison jérôme
les jeunes qui sont qui parle sans arrêt
d'environnement de climat etc
mais comment font-ils identifiant les
fêtes pour laisser alors que le sujet
est au coeur de la campagne municipale
où ils le disent c'est plus simple
qu'avant les parisiens sont plus salées
le 18ème passé ce qui est au fond dans
votre livre vous et votre film des
ordures et les hommes des hommes ce sont
les éboueurs et d'ordures bien fun ou
bien sur sa terre qui ne me servent même
pas là il faut savoir qu'il ya 3000
tonnes de déchets chaque jour quand même
juste sur la ville de par rapport à
paris c'est absolument énorme comment
endiguer une société du déchet à ce
point d'ailleurs ce qu'il faut savoir
c'est que vous savez que tout
s'entassent maintenant ce n'est plus
même plus le problème du tri sélectif se
jouer au delà de paris au delà de la
france c'est que les déchets sont
entassés et on ne sait plus avant ils
partent en chine la chine n'en veut plus
on ne peut pas les enfouir donc vous
avez des lieux en france et partout dans
le monde où ça s'entassent à santa comme
sedan c'est un film plein d'humanité il
ya des éclats de l'airé de lille mais
c'est aussi un film politique d'une
certaine façon
frédéric favelin est-ce qu'on peut
changer avec avec le civisme là on est
quand même au coeur d'un débat citoyen
fondamentale on se rend compte que
finalement on ne maîtrise pas
complètement la nature qu'on a un virus
et qu'il va falloir peut-être
redécouvrir un certain nombre de valeurs
faudra changer après cette crise je
pense que ça prend du temps c'est un peu
comme un spot de pub
même s'il est génial faut le répéter une
dix vingt trente fois pour que ça rentre
changer la façon de dire bonjour c'est
pas simple du tout dans la cuisine il ya
plein de gestes à apprendre
il ya des gens qui ne l'avait jamais
leur réfrigérateur alors il faut le
laver deux fois par mois parce que des
bactéries comme listeria qui se
développe en atmosphère froide et humide
et qui peuvent être extrêmement
dangereuses donc c'est toute une série
de réflexes d'hygiène quand on rentre à
la maison on enlève ses chaussures parce
qu'on marche ensuite pieds nus dans la
salle de bain pour aller au lit et c'est
au fond un grand défi donc ces centaines
être capable d'être à la hauteur de ces
principes là et léger
le civisme et sert même mais les gens
sont égoïstes
si on veut que ça marche il faut d'abord
parler de même là ça fonctionne ça c'est
le conseil du médecin qui va être
efficace
j'avais moi je remarque une chose par
rapport au bio ils ont eu des enquêtes
on en est c'est bien le genre 10 pour la
planète et tout mais quand on leur
demande c'est pour ma santé
parce qu'il ya moins d se décide donc en
train d'y aller par exemple aujourd'hui
il ya quand même la réserve mais
sanitaires qui se met en route il ya des
tonnes de médecins la retraite qui
arrive
il ya quand même de l'humanité dans
cette crise oui mais en même temps un
égoïsme farouche quand on dit par
exemple éviter de manger plus tu prenais
des sardines pour les oméga-3 plutôt que
des gros poisson parce que pour les
chaînes bonbons sur la détention il ya
moins de métaux lourds dans les sardines
que dans le ton a changé une habitude
unités aux instincts individuel merci
c'était très intéressant de vous
entendre comme ça des points de vue
différents sur sur ces questions je suis
sûr que la campagne américaine vous
intéresse
mais rassurez maria nin qui monte qui
semble même irrattrapable dans cette
primaire démocrate il s'appelle joe
biden est lui aussi il a dû faire
quelques ajustements coronavirus oblige
écoutez je tiens à remercier bernie
sanders et ses partisans pour leur
énergie et leur infatigable fassions
nous partageons un objectif commun
ensemble nous vaincrons donald trump
quand nous le vaincrons ensemble nous
rassemblerons 7 les suivre et tout de
suite c'est qu'il veut prendre sa place
avec françois durpaire single
[Musique]
qui veut prendre la place de donald
trump commenceront soir parler je suis
très disciplinés alors là on parle pas
du cours d'un virus à en parler de
donald trump
c'est touchant comment on va dire que
vous faites de lentilles 36 mhz donc
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé cette nuit
mini tuesday et très grosse victoire
pour pour joe biden puisque'il appel au
ralliement quand un candidat appel au
ralliement c'est que ça sent très bon
pour lui il gagne notamment de michigan
125 délégués et le michigan c'est ce qui
avait permis à sanders de revenir dans
la course ya quatre ans contre eux
hillary clinton donc c'est c'est très
mauvais pour sanders pourquoi parce
qu'on voit pas tellement comment il peut
revenir dans la course la semaine
prochaine ya une élection floride
et là ça semble aussi sondages sont très
très bons pour bayonne
alors qu'est ce qui s'est passé parce
que on avait commencé ses thèmes favoris
comme bad kids pourquoi mais parce que
d'abord la révolution jeunes les jeunes
se sont pas mobilisés
c'est à dire qu'effectivement les jeunes
votent pour sanders mais s'ils votent
pas il va pas beaucoup qui ne s'est pas
déplacé très peu et puis la deuxième
chose c'est qu'évidemment c'est la peur
de saunders dans le parti et en
particulier les vieux démocrate et il
voulait pas d'un socialiste comme
candidat il pensait qu'il avait aucune
chance contre donald trump donc donc ils
ont choisi bayh dole voyez c'est pas
gagné pour lui non plus parce que y
voyait il suscite quand même pas un
enthousiasme vous vous connaissez le
slogan de joe biden non moi non plus
personne ne le connaît donc c'est grave
c'est quand même très mauvaise a
toujours un slogan sur alors là non
qu'est ce qu'il disait il disait cette
nuit let's go jo alors let's go chaussée
quand même pas un grand message pour la
nation je connais le surnom clé de
naître et oui oui et oui tout dire ça
veut dire qu'il est un peu endormie ça
veut dire que c'est un candidat par
défaut et un peu chaperonné par son
ancien président obama alors est ce que
ça veut dire que trump a déjà gagné pas
forcément ce qui est un autre candidat
qui s'est un peu immiscé dans la course
et vous allez voir vous allez plutôt
entendre ce sont nous avions prévu un
grand meeting à cleveland ce soir
mais le gouverneur de l'ohio a demandé
aux campagnes présidentielles d'amuser
leur événement public rassemblant de
larges foules en intérieur à cleveland
et c'est ce que nous avons fait à cause
du corps aux navires ans le candidat
coronavirus si les démocrates ne peuvent
pas terrassé donald trump peut-être que
le coronavirus peu le terrasser en tout
cas c'est l'espoir des démocrates
puisque les démocrates ont dit quoi
depuis le départ donald trump n'a pas
l'étoffé d'un président qui pourraient
combattre ce fléau et faut quand même
reconnaître que donald trump il a
commencé par dire les américains ça peut
toucher l'ensemble du monde mais pas les
américains comme si les américains peu
emule etc mais il y avait zéro mort à
l'époque matin en à peine deux
américains ils font un peu plus la tête
il y avait 60 personnes atteintes il y
en a maintenant cinq cents donc ça veut
dire que il a sans doute minimiser ce
qu'il a appelé une grippe exotiques
la deuxième chose ça c'est le ca si vous
voulez les démocrates y critique donald
trump on a l'habitude ce qui est un peu
plus grave c'est l'économie c'est
l'effet indirect sur la croissance
américaine parce que récession ça rime
pas avec réélection ça rime mais en fait
c est quand même rien à voir donc
évidemment il fait pression sur la fête
de dalton pour baisser les taux pour
relancer la demande
il a promis aussi de baisser les
cotisations sociales tout est bon pour
maintenir cette économie dans son étape
à ce que l'économie c'est quand même la
tourille mal de direction il a déjà
gagné pour les femmes il pourra toujours
dire c'est la faute du coronavirus parce
que d'un je pense que il va avoir un
gros dos ce virus un oui à 74 ans donald
78 oui obaida 150 ans à eux deux ça
promet vraiment belle de vieillard alors
c'est pas le problème qu'ils soient
vieillard parce que 150 ans à eux deux
s'ils ont des idées neuves
sauf que vous allez avoir un président
qui va dire c'est la continuité j'ai été
très très bien dans mon premier mandat
d'ailleurs font slogan elle-même qui
peut america great même slogan
et puis vous avez vous avez entendu
cette nuit le discours de bail donne il
dit très clairement
moi ce que je veux c'est surtout de
restaurer un peu la dignité la décence à
la maison blanche
un peu léger comme vous intéresse quand
vous voyez des candidats quand même
assez âgées dans une campagne vous dites
quoi les américains sont en bonne santé
non je dis qu'ils sont jeunes parce que
tout simplement aujourd'hui 75 ans
soixante dix huit ans c'est jeune en
fait on a découvert que la créativité
vous allez le cerveau c'est comme là bas
c'est pas un métier d'athlète d'être
président on pensait avant qu'on essaie
qu'un stock de neurones et qui à la fin
tu venais gâteux c'est pas vrai du tout
si par exemple aujourd'hui en effet ni
règle pour mesurer la taille de notre
cerveau et puis on décide de rentrer
tous dans un cirque on apprend à jongler
pendant trois mois dans trois mois qu'on
va nous refaire un irm une nouvelle zone
du cerveau ce sera formée en fait on
peut augmenter la capacité cérébrale
à condition de faire tout le temps des
choses nouvelles on apprend de
l'instrument de musique une langue
étrangère
on va pas tous les ans le landeron en
vacances on découvre de nouvelles
cuisines et quelque part les vieux et
dangereux
l'activité ce qui est dangereux c'est la
retraite
d'ailleurs une étude est sortie montrant
quels points communs des hommes qui
développait alzheimer ces retraites
précoces
vous savez einstein disait la vie c'est
comme la bicyclette on arrête de pédaler
en tombent
on est comme des montres automatiques on
se recharge dans le mouvement et là ils
font la preuve qu' ils sont des jeunes
gens 75,78 très jeunes ils ont encore un
avenir brillant devant eux
allez merci beaucoup retard est la
douzième et non on n'est pas au meilleur
de sa forme à 91
je voudrais quand même comparé la bande
de vaulx mireille dumas merci à tous
merci françois mercredi prochain une
nouvelle chronique sur la campagne
américaine
on va parler un petit peu de votre
carrière aussi alors vous les avez tous
interviewé pas seulement les politiques
ce sont eux qui nous intéresse ce soir
mais souvient de vos émissions avec des
détenus avec les transsexuels avec des
aventuriers aussi alors à mes désirs et
ses plans ce plan de plongée dans les
archives de vos émissions avec des
hommes et des femmes politiques chaîne
parlementaire oblige on regarde et on en
parle juste après
je vous ai dit mireille dumas à la fin
de l'émission jolie dans votre tête
non c'est le contraire ce sera le
contraire c'est la reine de l'interview
confidences
mireille dumas c'est d'abord des
émissions cultes à la télévision au
début des années 90 bas les masques
la vie à l'endroit ou encore vie privée
vie publique
présentatrice mais aussi réalisatrice de
documentaires comme ici en 1998 à
l'assemblée nationale l'histoire de
notre république c'est ici qu'elle
s'écrit depuis 200 ans
ils sont aujourd'hui 577 députés et plus
de mille deux cents fonctionnaires à
travailler à l'assemblée nationale à
lire à yuma et les politiques c'est
assez spécial
une façon différente de parler pour
dresser un portrait nouveau les faire
sortir de la langue de bois comme ici
mireille dumas demande à ses invités de
se raconter au travers des chansons qui
ont marqué leurs fruits
ça donne des moments surprenants comme
avec jean pierre raffarin faisant du air
guitar
les fans de johnny quand je vais au
concert de johnny et que je vois tout le
monde que je t'aime que j'aime quand je
regarde les jeunes dames qui sont avec à
côté de moi 65 ans des mères
il a 40 ans n'étaient pas les mêmes non
plus à des interviews frontières de la
vie publique et de la vie intime comme
avec valéry giscard d'estaing qui
explique devant l'interview veut
imperturbable que le pouvoir attire
comme un aimant et au niveau de la
séduction
est-ce que ça rend plus irrésistible oui
ça c'est vous dire une chose très memish
sérieux c'est l'attrait des femmes pour
le pauvre qu'est ce que c'est alors ne
me posais pas la question parce qu'alors
justement je voudrais pas vous déplaire
je me pose à quêter pouvez pas vous non
ah je suis désolé une fascination une
fascination pour les hommes c'est plus
compliqué pour les femmes de pouvoir si
ces dites moi justement vos femmes
politiques comment vous êtes perçu par
les hommes est ce que le pouvoir attirer
les joueurs aux hommes novikov qui
veulent être à la hauteur
ils veulent être à la hauteur
puis il faut que je sois je pense qu'il
faudrait fléchissent performance voilà
la marque de fabrique du mât avec les
politiques faire parler différemment un
peu
à la manière de freud convoqué le passé
les souvenirs pour expliquer
l'engagement d'aujourd'hui
s'il ya un politique qui a bien connu
mireille dumas c'est andré santini
ancien député trois fois ministre tous
deux ont écrit ensemble mère célibataire
un livre où l'élu se raconte
il dit avoir été torturé ses pairs que
tout faire que tout parce qu'elle fait
semblant ne pas vous connaître vous pose
la question et vous gratte à tel endroit
et ont diminué ou niort comme elle est
gentille cubes en ont pris un coup sur
la tête
oui c'est un âge l'attendait mais je
pensais que elle n'oserait pas l os
elle n'ose elle n'ose mireille lauze
alors osons nous aussi à vous maintenant
mireille de passer à l'interview
confidences alors on va la faire cette
interview au ballet masquer le temps
pour moi de saluer nos invités bonsoir
monsieur le maire je peux encore vous
appelez au 8 mars normalement
voilà c'est pas encore la fin puisque
vous êtes yves fafournoux et votre fils
kevin bonsoir vous a suivi avec une
caméra dans les derniers dernières
semaines derniers mois de votre mandat
dans une petite ville d'auvergne on en
vient on y vient dans quelques minutes
mais d'abord bas les masques un petit
peu ce soir
mais raph dumas si vous êtes 1,4 oui
comme le dit valéry giscard d'estaing
qu'est ce qui vous fascine chez les
hommes si ce n'est pas leur pouvoir
le pouvoir ne fascine justement
absolument pas c'est ce que je disais
qu'est ce que vous cherchez un président
au fond non non c'est dans tout ce dont
elle avait interdit bien sûr d'installer
notre par demand humanité commune ce qui
m'intéresse c'est la façon dont on se
construit où on est déconstruit aussi
par par la vie donc l'enfant ça serait
caricatural mais par la vie en général
faya n'intéresse pas uniquement
justement la construction la
déconstruction mais aussi la
construction ce qui m'intéresse c'est
comment on peut rebondir parce que si
vous
si vous entendez bien souvent les
interviews que j'ai fait c'est la façon
dont on va justement pouvoir rebondir
après des difficultés quelles qu'elles
soient
c'est ses sorties au cesci maintenant
rend plus forts les échecs et oui ça
fait qu'on avance a que moi je suis
toujours étonné par la façon dont dans
les gens se débrouillent de leur vie et
j'ai cette curiosité insatiable parce
que la vie est évidemment et l'individu
à une amie une imagination absolument
extraordinaire on parle beaucoup en ce
moment des femmes puissantes
oui un grand sujet celle qui à la fois
désir et exerce le pouvoir
est-ce que vous en êtes une fan de
pouvoir me sentais pas forcément chez
elle un jour arriver là où vous êtes et
je ne me suis jamais ressenti comme cela
je pense que ce qui m'a vraiment c'est
mon métier de journaliste et
réalisatrice qui monte qui monte guider
vers l'autre il s'avère que pour pouvoir
avoir plus de liberté
je pense pour pouvoir exercer mon métier
en toute liberté
je suis devenue productrice mais plus
dans ce sens là pour pouvoir avoir de la
liberté non pour avoir du pouvoir et
j'ai adoré produire aussi d'autres
personnes c'est à dire en fait passer
aussi aider les autres lequel de tous
ces politiques et femmes politiques
finalement vous a plu le plus marqué
gardez qui dans toutes ces images
impressionnait 1 je crois que certains
c'est le vous savez passer par le prisme
de la chanson pour les faire parler
c'est absolument extraordinaire parce
que effectivement ça peut ce que dit
andreck c'est amusant parce que
j'adresse d'augmenter ce oui ça commence
comme ça par une chanson et tout est en
fait comme il parle de la chanson ça me
donne matière tout de suite à apposer
des à poser des questions et à rentrer
dans le vif du sujet d'une autre manière
ça c'était absolument formidable donc
tous m'ont étonné mais valéry giscard
d'estaing m'a vraiment ça m'avait fait
tellement rire c'est un extraordinaire
je crois parce que à la fin à la fin il
me dit quand même que je suis une femme
de néandertal donc je lui dis mais vous
savez être fasciné par le pouvoir de
l'homme j'ai l'impression que son ouïe
les femmes qui sont fascinés par le
pouvoir de l'homme n'ont peut-être ont
peut-être encore à apprendre mon lait de
la séduction dans un entretien dans
interview en direct oui mais là c'est la
seule à échouer à ce moment là takumi
savez qu'il ya toujours de la séduction
dans un entretien mais entre vous et moi
individus pas forcément entre hommes et
femmes moi je n'ai jamais fais mes
entretiens en pensant que j'avais un
homme ou une femme en face de moi est ce
que ça me manque pas du tout non pas du
tout paris hier à votre place avec
pascale clark elle c'était la radio elle
disait c'est une drogue c'est reda urnes
leurs arrêtés oui non pas du tout parce
que moi je n'ai jamais arrêté
je continue à faire des documentaires à
faire des entretiens comme la retrouver
les agents de la propreté les éboueurs
retrouver des anonymes des artistes je
suis allé j'ai tendu mon micro si je
puis dire un petit peu à tout le monde
et que ce métier j'ai continué de
l'examen découvrir mettrait d'ailleurs
réglementariste un bien j'ai commencé ma
relevé devant ou derrière la caméra pour
moi c'est la même chose
à partir du moment où je peux faire des
films je peux interviewé si je ne
pouvais pas effectivement exercer mon
métier je serais très très triste vous
savez analyser pour devrait commencer
qu'analyste leur donnerait jamais mais
pas du genou n'a jamais tenté mais
jamais jamais et je ne sais franchement
c'est très bien pour ceux qui ont envie
mais moi je n'ai jamais eu ce souhait ni
ce désir ni ni cette obligation va dire
et j'ai toujours pas besoin d'avoir fait
une analyse pour faire du mirail
d'humains mais surtout par je crois que
si j'avais fait une analyse je crois que
me sera interdite justement beaucoup de
beaucoup de questions et je ne les
aurais peut-être pas posé de la même
façon je pense que voilà c'est plus vous
savez l'écoutent
le fait d'être écoutés qui a fait qu
enfin d'écouter les autres qui a fait
dire que j'avais une écoute
psychanalytique mais on va voir parce
que là c'est un regard et une écoute
aussi d'un fils sur son père kevin
fafournoux va voir un extrait de votre
film c'est un film un premier film plein
d'admiration plein d'amour c'est un film
politique et c'est un film sur sur la
filiation ça s'appelle la gloire de mon
père on part tout de suite avait
remontons en auvergne la ville dans
laquelle vous avez passé 25 ans demande
à la ville que vous avez quittez
extraits
là c'est mon père et moi en train de
contempler la jolie fille je lui demande
si tout ça ne va pas trop lui manque et
tout ça c'est veyre-monton c'est mon
village de 3500 habitants localisé en
auvergne c'est la pile au milieu de la
france a est aussi le maire ici c'est
mon père il a mais dernière pour le 14
juillet ils fassent pour nous c'est
comme ça qu'ils s'appellent annoncer
quelque chose qui m'a vraiment surpris
et après 25 ans ce sera la dernière fête
nationale en tant que mère que je
présiderai c'est à ce moment là que j'ai
eu besoin de comprendre les raisons son
choix de revenir sur ce qui a fait la
gloire de mon maître
alors qu'avec vous compris kevin
fourneaux bien des mots compris de ce
père maire de sète j'ai compris plein de
choses
premier à premièrement en fait j'ai
compris oui passer tout son temps quand
j'étais plus petit puisque effectivement
ça a commencé très jeune les dix huit
ans tout à fait et donc j'ai a eu un
père un petit peu plus absents quimper
normal mais bon j'en veux pas du tout va
la mener ces c'est vrai que c'est
il était absente beaucoup de réunions
beaucoup de beaux coups bas 2-2 de
dévouement par rapport à cette fonction
et c'est vrai que vous devez comprendre
pourquoi autant de lui même
oui tout à fait il ya une vraie volonté
de comprendre déjà les rouages de la
mairie comment on fonctionne ça la
fonction de maire tout simplement et
puis et puis voilà voir comment
s'organise un emploi du temps comment
comment il gérait tout ça en fait
finalement
ouais ça prend beaucoup de temps ça
déborde je crois que c'est vraiment
quelque chose que j'ai découvert c'est
le jeu c'est le dévouement que suscite
cette 7,7 fonctions notamment ben voilà
tout ce qui est réunion tous qui eux les
missions qui sont qui sont qui sont
liées à sa fin que ça se fonction demers
c'est assez impressionnant il ya
beaucoup de choses à faire et c'est vrai
que ça ça demande un emploi du temps à
100% vous voulez montrer aussi comment
cette fonction de maire à porter
d'engueulades c'est ce que dira
régulièrement un président de la
république a changé à évoluer en fait
j'ai été très surpris il ya un an contre
quand mon père m'a dit j'en ai marre
j'ai envie de démissionner alors ça nous
a surpris pas que moi il ya ma soeur ma
mère aussi parce que c'est quelque chose
qui kilani profondément ses 25 ans
quelque chose qui qui on la tourne a
toujours connu ça à la mairie et quand
on entend dire j'ai envie de
démissionner je me suis dit à un
problème quelque chose qui se passe et
vous inquiétez ça m'a inquiété fois je
me suis dit il ya quelque chose qui se
passe bien je sais pas quoi mais voilà
il donc j'ai fait mes recherches j'ai
trouvé beaucoup d'articles sur le sujet
beaucoup d'inquiétudes sur les mers a
tué aussi une étude très intéressante
ceux du cevipof le centre politiques de
sciences po qui mettait en avant des
chiffres assez importants sur le bout
des mères qui avaient vraiment envie de
démissionner et d'arrêter en 2020 et je
me suis dit tiens c'est alors pourquoi
raccrocher je crois qu'il a résumé pas
mal de choses
au bout d'un moment on essaye de donner
de sa personne et puis on se rend compte
que de donner de données
en retour je n'attendais pas de
remerciements c'est parce que je veux
dire mais de du respect de par la
fonction j'aurais juste était le seul
comme on dit je me serais dit bon c'est
prétentieux de ma part mais je ne suis
pas le seul malheureusement on est de
nombreux dans cette dans cette démarche
là à peu plus vouloir poursuivre
pourquoi parce que la société pour nous
a changés a beaucoup changé et on a des
difficultés à se faire comprendre il
assuré alors qu'est-ce que je suis le
consommateur ou alors tout à fait gens
je me suis retrouvé devant des citoyens
alors c'est pas l'ensemble bien sûr il
ya toujours des gens qui sont
respectueux mais de plus en plus on
trouve de deux personnes qui ne veulent
pas que la société fonctionne telle
qu'elle est c'est-à-dire qu'ils veulent
la changer c'est vrai qu'on doit la
changer mondiale elle a changé
démocratiquement douala changé avec des
réflexions douala changé avec la
communication mais on doit pas la
changer dans la violence verbale ou quoi
que ce soit et aujourd'hui on a plus de
violence verbale que l'on a de
satisfaction je veux dire de retours de
satisfaction du mal
l'incivilité à faire un peu de don de
soi à faire partie d'une forme de
société solidaire vous le constater
concrètement
oui l'agression l'agression elle et elle
et je vais pas dire permanente sinon il
ya des bons moments faut pas non plus
mais l'agression si vous voulez elles
existent elles existent au devant mon
portail la mairie c'est pas mon portail
c'est pas ma maison
la mairie c'est la mairie elle existe
dans la rue à je vous vois je vais vous
dire un truc ça ça va pas
harcelés en fait le numéro de téléphone
portable je vois là absolument le
portable est quelque chose qui était
merveilleux parce qu'on a pu nous
joindre à tout moment simplement qu'il
est diffusé
le numéro est diffusé on a beau le
cacher on a beau tout ce que vous voulez
et on vous appelle le matin vous appelle
la nuit on vous appelle à tout moment
non ça pour une rémunération de 1664
euros par mois que je répare tissés avec
mes conseillers délégués ajoie donc
c'était pas ce que je touchais je tiens
à le dire mais sans prétention aucune
j'estime que j'avais une salaire puisque
je suis à la retraite au cid de la
société orange mais effectivement pour
qu'il y ait plus de gens qui
s'investissent de consignes comme en dh
d'adjoints et de conseillers qui
s'investissent je donnais une
participation donc demandé ma masse de
plus en plus je voudrais dire de
responsabilité pour les mères très sada
garde c'est ce qui me sidère kévin lafon
nouveau liste est d'ailleurs la liste 1
oui c'était délicieux dans l'émission de
mer qui ne cesse de tourmenter crème
effectivement il y en a il y en a toute
une liste incroyable et c'est vrai que
ça n'est pas ce pour moi ça dépasse
l'entendement parce que les choses qui
sont vraiment pour le coup qui devrait
pas être lié au maire mais ça fait
beaucoup beaucoup de travail en réalité
c'est une décision que votre père après
seul vous avez été surpris mais est ce
que madame était au courant comme elle
attendait ça avec impatience
madame attendait ça avec impatience
effectivement
c'est au détriment de pas de la vie mais
c'est au détriment de pas mal de choses
souvent c'est elle qui vous a poussée au
début aix est alors accompagné
elle m'a accompagné mais je me rappelle
au début faut se mettre dans excusez moi
l'expression dans le bain je suis dit
pendant six mois tu vas pas trop me voir
souvent au bout de six ans elle m'a dit
les six mois sont pas finis voyez donc
cesser constance et qu'on se disait même
que c'est dans le film de votre choix
je n'ai pas vu la mer et il faut voir ça
devient très urgent ça vous a plu d'être
suivi par d'autres
c'était oui ça m'a plu et nous ment mais
j'avais peur plus de l'encombrer que de
2,2 d'avoir une à satisfaite à dire lui
donner une insatisfaction ne pas être
disons à la hauteur de ce qu'il
attendait de son père ou du maire a mais
c'est je suis triste événement il s'est
extrêmement prêter au jeu
on voulait vue vous le film lui l'a pas
vu mais c'est vrai que toutes les
petites saynètes qu'on a joué tout tout
tout les deux les choses qu'il a fallu
refaire passe quelque chose qui marchait
paraît que ça ça c'était génial et c'est
ce qui fait la force de ce film c'est la
relation père fils et j'en suis très
content une relation père fils qui
change quand c'est une relation aussi
fils mère est ma qu'est ce que ça fait
d'avoir un papa qui était aussi accaparé
par par les habitants d'un village quand
votre mère explique quand même que c'est
la mairie sa maîtresse oui oui ça c'est
fou on réalise et je pense que cette
volonté de faire un film elle doit y
être aussi pour peut-être faire une
psychanalyse ou quelque chose parce que
ça évidemment ça m'a beaucoup marqué ça
a commencé très tôt et puis ça ah bon
c'est encore maintenant bon après je
suis parti de la maison donc un parti
mouvement je suis parti j'ai fait mes
études ex terrasse savait plus le même
j'avais pu même ressenti puisque plus
par rapport à ma mère qui était vraiment
en première ligne il accompagne tous les
jours mais moi c'est vrai que quand
j'étais petit c'était plus difficile à
l'école j'ai entendu des choses qui
étaient pas vraiment très sympathique et
mon égard pour le maire extrait ça bon
voilà c'est pas des choses qui eux le
collège a été pareil pas forcément très
très haut très sympa aussi dont barbra
cette situation là mais de regrets parce
que dans le film vous dites que
seulement 1%
tout ce que vous avez fait vous avez
vraiment apporté cette espèce
alors quand je dis aux % c'est vrai
qu'ayant % de satisfaction on a des
on ad ce qu'on appelle les réceptions
des manifestations qui sont des
inaugurations ça ça fait partie des
choses le leur gré leur graisse je vais
vous je vais être sincère c'est pas
pouvoir continuer d'ailleurs ne pas
vouloir continuer voyez c'est pas et
voilà c'est un scoop mais non j'avais
pris une décision et je ne voulais pas
revenir en arrière
parce qu'effectivement je sentais bien
que cette société qui change
je n'étais plus en phase avec elle je la
rejette pas j'essaye de la comprendre
mais je la comprends pas c'est ça la
difficulté
donc quand on comprend pas quelque chose
soit on les tue 10 soit on se force à
poursuivre je n'ai pas envie soit j'ai
pas j'ai pas j'ai pas eu envie d'être en
conflit avec des gens certains
j'apprécie parce qu'effectivement
aujourd'hui nos sociétés on n'a pas le
droit de dire non on le voit bien avec
ce qui se passe notre société on n'a pas
le droit de dire non on doit suivre et
on est en exactement pareil dans les
petites communes c'est à dire qu'une
personne qui vous met en avant c'est à
quelque chose elle elle voudrait que ça
soit suivi d'effets vous lui dites non
c'est pas possible il ya une règle et un
règlement et à qui de vous deux
appréhende le plus quand ça va s'arrêter
vraiment en fait moi j'appelle 1 2 par
lui parce qu'en fait en réalité ils
passent énormément de temps là bas est
en fait d'arrêter cette passion cette
chose qui l'animent du jour en main est
passé de tout à rien je stresse un peu
pour lui 1 % de joie de satisfaction
pleine et entière il ya cette image que
je voulais absolument vous montrer c'est
aller à la fin du film mais il faut le
voir absolument
ce film la gloire de mon père c'est vous
et vous allez marié kevin love votre
fils est un missile a laissé le moment
de l'apogée du film c c'est le moment
qu'ont à partager ensemble cette année
et c'est vrai que je voulais c'était
quelque chose que je voulais vraiment
faire être que mariette à mon père je
vis au delà il faut en profiter et bon
c'était un moment extraordinaire c'est
que ça laissera des traces c'est sur ces
voies la plus belle des psychanalyses
vécu avec 80 ans et sarah tout tout tout
tout tout cas on a tous fait une
magnifique et j'ai franchement une
page d'amour filial manille et ça
s'appelle la gloire de mon père et s'est
diffusée pardonnez-moi lundi soir lundi
prochain à 20h30 sur lcp le vôtre de
films et de livres mais le film lui
mireille dumas il est diffusé demain
soir merci infiniment on va sculpter
avec le deuxième volet de notre série
documentaire sur rouen
aujourd'hui on va aller à la rencontre
des citoyens des citoyens engagés après
l incendie lusine l'oubli lubrizol rouen
à l'ombre du nuage ces signes de
nathalie gloire et françois chevrel
[Musique]
ça va
alors là on arrive dans le site dans le
début de la zone industrielle de ce
secteur de roi on sait qu'il ya des
usines mais on ne savait pas à quel
point il pouvait être hautement toxique
dire qu'on savait pas que on n'imaginait
pas que ça pouvait arriver jusqu'à chez
nous cinq mois après l'incendié de
lubrizol les odeurs juste devant l'usiné
persiste
simon de carvalho font partie des
fondateurs de l'association des
sinistrés de lubrizol
il se bat pour connaître la vérité sur
les produits qu'ils ont brûlés dans la
nuit du 26 septembre
le collectif a été créé parce que on a
manqué cruellement d'informations mais
qu'on veut la vérité on veut savoir pour
nos enfants pour nos anciens pour nous
mêmes quelle est la nature de cette
intoxication
on a bien compris que l'état n'allait
pas faire le travail et que donc c'était
à nous nous citoyens de faire le job
et ce soir justement simon de carvalho
se rend à une réunion du collectif
associations syndicats mais aussi
citoyens sont présents autour de la
table leurs stratégies continuer à
mettre la pression durant la campagne
des municipales pour ne pas oublier ce
qui s'est passé le 26 septembre à rouen
il ya pas un seul candidat qui va pas
parler de lubrizol
donc effectivement faut que nous on
apparaît c'est qu'on apparaissent en
dynamique et pas un petit rassemblement
bon moi je pense qu'il faut y aller sur
la manif à ce collectif se présente
comme apolitique
alors ici on fait bien la distinction
entre les municipales et ce qui s'est
passé à l'efb reason et donc l'idée pour
nous je sais pas si c'est de mettre la
pression sur le prochain maire mais en
tout cas ces deux cadencés on va dire ça
comme ça
des initiatives a fait un mois deux mois
4 mois 6 mois
on s'inscrit dans la durée très
précisément on est là on sera là en
rapport à la lutte que l'on mène un
maire ou un autre ce sera à lui de se
positionner correctement mais nous ça
change rien par rapport
l' usine chimique fait bouger des
citoyens méchant boutel aussi la
campagne des municipales de rouen demain
portraits des candidats qui font
campagne sous l'ombre de lubrizol
voilà la suite de notre série sur rouen
à retrouver demain merci merci mireille
dumas vous irez voir le film de votre
fils un lundi soir à saint jean mais
peut-être un petit peu avant même un peu
bavard faudra frapper des ordures et des
hommes c'est avec downing dominion c'est
un livre à venir et dumas est un film et
c'est celui là demain soir je leur dis
ne ratait pas 20h30 sur lcp très belle
soirée et à demain
[Musique]